Did you guys see God takes
responsibility for the actions of Satan?
He says to Satan in Job 2:3, "You
incited me against him to destroy him
without cause." Well, number one, you
didn't destroy him, God. You didn't
bring those afflictions. Satan did.
Satan did those actions, but God had to
give him permission. And in giving him
permission, God is taking responsibility
for actions he himself did not
commit. Do we get that?
Now, now let me give you another example
where God is said to be responsible for
something that Satan incited someone to
do. 1st Chronicles
21:1, now Satan stood up against Israel
and moved David to number Israel. Now
let me explain the
context. David started trusting in the
size and number of Israel and his army
instead of God. Pay attention guys.
Please focus. No side talks. I'm going
to start blocking
people. Okay.
David started getting very comfortable
with the size of Israel and the number
of his army. So he was trusting in his
num in the numbers the numbers of the
people and of his soldiers. He was
trusting in numbers not in God. And
because of that sin in his heart, Satan
seeing that sin then pricricked David
and moved David to now number how many
Israelites and how many soldiers he had
which angered God and moved God to
punish
David. You understand what the context
is? And this is another thing Satan
does. Satan
knows your sinful
inclinations. He knows what makes you
tick and what will cause you to stumble.
So he knows maybe you're addicted to
food, right? So he'll be constantly
whispering in your
ear in order to tempt you to think about
the very thing that will ensnare you or
sex. He knows. So he's whispering in
your ear, constantly reminding you of
the very thing that you have a hard time
resisting in order to succumb to that
temptation and sin against
God. You with me
there? So
David was trusting in the size of the
people and the size of his army instead
of trusting in the power of God to
preserve Israel.
And so Satan seeing that David was now
taking comfort and soloulless and
confidence in the size of the people as
opposed to the power of God. Then move
David to then number them. Take a
census. Hey David, just so you can be a
little more comfortable. Go and take a
census. See how many people there are
and how many soldiers you have. So that
now you can be completely assured you're
safe because of your numbers.
Now 1st Chronicles
21:1, who moved Satan to do that? 1st
Chronicles
21:1. Okay. Now, Satan stood up against
Israel and moved David to number Israel.
So, it's Satan, right? Hold on. 2 Samuel
24:1. No, Jesus is my Lord. 1st
Chronicles
21:1, who moved David, incited David?
Satan. But 2 Samuel
24:1 Samuel
24:1 again the anger of Jehovah was
aroused against Israel and he moved
David against him to say go number
Israel and Judah Judah.
Uhoh. Who moved David to number Israel
and Judah? God. But in 1st Chronicles
21:1, it's
Satan. So, did God move David to expose
the sin in his heart and in the heart of
his people for trusting in their size
and their wealth? Or did Satan do
that? Satan did with God's
permission. It wasn't God who moved Sat
David. It wasn't God who moved David to
act upon his sinful inclination, giving
birth to sin. God doesn't do that. He
doesn't tempt you with evil. He won't
prick you to act upon your evil sinful
inclinations. That's something you
either do because of your sinful
passions andor because of the
instigation of Satan.
So then why is 2 Samuel 24:1 saying God
did it? Come on man, the answer is
simple now. Are we seeing a pattern here
in scripture?
It's only a contradiction in the minds
of Bible perverts who don't want to
read in a manner to
reconcile the overall teaching of the
Bible when it comes to God's sovereignty
and the decisions of
creatures. You get my point?
So, did God move David to act upon the
evil desires of his heart? That would
contradict James
1:13. It was Satan who moved David to
act upon the evil desires of his heart.
And once he gave birth to those evil
desires, he then sinned against God. So
then why is
God taking responsibility? Because
again, this is how the Bible's written.
The actions committed by
creatures are actions that God allows
and permits because those actions will
then be used by God in his infinite
power and wisdom to bring about a
greater good, a greater
purpose. Everyone
clear? Let me give you another one.
Ezekiel
14 verses 9 and 10. This one really
troubles
people. It really tr what? No.
No. I thought Yahweh wasn't like I love
the Quran. No, no,
no. This really troubles
people. And if the prophet, he's talking
about false prophets. If you read
Ezekiel 13 and 14, he's talking about
false prophets.
And if the prophet be deceived when he
had spoken a thing, I Jehovah have
deceived that prophet. No, no, no. Why?
Why?
Why? I Jehovah deceive that
prophet, and I will stretch out my hand
upon him and will destroy him from the
midst of my people Israel, and they
shall bear the punishment of their
iniquity. The punishment of the prophet
shall be even as the punishment of him
that seeketh unto him. That sure sounds
like Calvinism is true. Did you catch
it? If the prophet is deceived to
deceive people with false prophecies,
lies and falsehood. No, I deceive the
prophet to deceive them. And then I'm
going to punish him for deceiving them
even though I deceived him to deceive
them. And I'm going to punish them for
believing him.
Now you want to know the answer to
this. You want to know the answer to
this one? So who deceived the false
prophet to deceive the
people? Jehovah. So that mean Jehovah's
Allah. God forbid such blasphemy.
Because now let's explain what it means.
Are you ready? Let's explain what it
means.
Okay, let's explain what it
means. First Kings
22:19-23. Now, you're going to get the
answer and hopefully it'll blow you
away. Now, by the way, I've done
sessions on these already. I've already
explained these in the past. Now, let's
see what it
means. First Kings
22:19-23. Okay, now read. This is the
king of Judah and the king of Israel
about to go to battle in Ramath Gilead.
And there are prophets telling the king
of Israel, Ahab, go for Jehovah has
given you the victory because these were
false
prophets
deceiving
Ahab into thinking God had said he'd
win. So a true prophet, Micaiah, tells
him the true story. Now watch. Micaiah
the true prophet tells him the reason
why these prophets are telling you God
has decreed you're going to win. Let me
tell you what took place in heaven. Now
read with me first kings 22 19 to23. And
he said here thou therefore the word of
Jehovah Yahwah. After this you can go
back to the New King James. I saw Yahweh
Jehovah. See, I said that in heaven you
see God visibly in a visible shape that
he
assumes sitting on a throne visibly. So
you can behold God and see God, right? I
saw Yahweh Job sitting on his throne and
all the hosts of heaven standing by him
on his right hand and on his left. Now
pay attention. And he Jehovah said, "Who
shall persuade Ahab?" Now, by the way,
the word persuade is the same Hebrew
word deceived in Ezekiel 14:9-10. It's
the same Hebrew word.
Pa pa. Someone say path. It's the same
Hebrew word. Who shall persuade, entice,
deceive Ahab that it may go up and fall
at Ramoth Gilead? And one said on this
manner and another said on that manner.
Now watch. Does
God literally speak deceitful
words? Does any deceitful word come out
of his mouth?
Watch. And there came forth a spirit and
stood before Jehovah Yahweh and said, "I
will deceive, entice, induce, persuade
him." And Jehovah said unto him,
"Wherewith, how how are you going to do
it?" Notice it's not God telling the
spirit how to do it. So notice how
beautifully written the Bible is. So
that you don't think God is the one
telling the spirit what to say. He's
asking how. Why do you think God is
asking? So that
blasphemers, Bible perverts won't say
that God taught the spirit what to say.
No. The spirit out of his own vition and
free will came up with this
plan. Because what did God say? How how
are you going to do it? And he said, I
will go forth and I will be a lying
spirit in the mouth of all his prophets.
Bam. That's what it means. God deceived
the false prophet. And then what did God
say? All right, you shall persuade him
and prevail also. Go forth and do so.
Now therefore, behold, Jehovah had put a
lying spirit in the mouth of all these
thy prophets, and Jehovah had spoken
evil concerning thee. Now, what's
ironic, Jehovah didn't put any spirit in
them. The spirit himself volunteered and
voluntarily came to the prophets and
inspired all of them to lie and deceive
Ahab. So, are you seeing how biblical
language works?
Again, God didn't literally take the
spirit and plant that spirit in all of
them. The spirit volunteered.
He stepped forward, volunteered, and he
voluntarily went with God's
permission. Do you see how deep and rich
the Bible is? and that you must read it
carefully, handle it with care and
reverence and not just simply gloss over
it or you're going to miss the depth and
meat of scripture and say things of God
that are untrue like Calvinists do with
their
tulip. Do you get it? Now, here's what's
more
ironic. You know what's more ironic and
shocking? Ahab was actually then told
the
truth. Micaiah told Ahab, "By the way,
Ahab, they're all lying to you because
an evil spirit has caused all of them to
lie to you and deceive you to go to
battle, be killed because the fact of
the matter is God has decreed that
you're going to have to die for your
sin." So he was then told the truth and
Hab still went to battle and still got
killed. Everyone getting
it? You see how amazing the Bible
is? So if you got it, let me ask the
question. See if you're getting it.
Number one, does God ever
speak lies and deceitful, deceptive
words to any
prophet? Does he speak audibly to a
prophet and tell prophet lies and
deceitful words for that prophet to pass
on?
Nope. Who does that? Lying evil spirits.
So it's not God but lying evil spirits
that God allows to deceive false
prophets. Which leads me to the second
point. Why is God allowing false
prophets to be inspired by lying spirits
to spread lies and deceit to people?
Because that's the judgment upon people
who hate the truth, who hate God's word
and true prophets. So then God gives
them what they want. And that tells you
not every
prophet is speaking out of his own
imagination. Here you're told there are
prophets who do see spirits, spirits who
appear as righteous beings to deceive
them to lie like
Muhammad. So not every false prophet,
false Christ is simply speaking from his
own imagination. Many of them do see
spirits, but these spirits appear as
righteous beings who convince them
they're from God to deceive them, to
deceive
others. Everyone got it?